You know, in our increasingly
interconnected world,
when so many signals are
competing for our attention,
we are essentially flooded
by too much possibility.
We are overcome by
bandwidth anxiety because
of the sheer paradox of
choice, the paralysis,
the vertigo of freedom, as
Timothy Leary says, we almost
like, can't help but suffer from
an acute affliction of FOLO,
otherwise known as the
fear of missing out.
And I'm reminded of a line from
the movie, "Mr. Nobody," when
he says, "as long
as you don't choose,
everything remains possible."
And there's kind of
safety in abstaining
from actually
committing to anything.
As long as you don't
commit, you literally
reside in a multiverse of
infinite possibilities.
You reside in a state of
quantum super position.
The minute you
commit to something,
when you choose one
thing, you collapse
all other possibilities and
you find yourself instead,
in the desert of
the real, that state
of potentiality, that state
before you make that commitment
is a state where
anything can happen.
The minute you choose
one thing, you've
effectively said no
to everything else.
And there's a gnawing
anxiety in realizing
that you can't
possibly have it all.
You can't possibly
mainline space and time
through the optic nerve and
have and swallow it whole.
Because that whole line
from the Bible about
you know, Adam taking
from the tree of knowledge
and biting the apple.
You know, we didn't
just bite the apple,
we swallowed it whole.
We want the whole thing.
And I think that's the reason
that we suffer from this,
from FOLO, you know,
because it's just,
it's intestinal to
who we really are
and what we really
long for, so much
more so much more than what
we're currently privy to.
For that reason, I think
that agitation is actually,
actually not a bad thing.
You know, if we suffer
from fear of missing out,
it just shows that you have
an intuition that there's
something greater.
Maybe I'm romanticizing the
sort of affliction of our age,
but that's certainly
what I choose to think.